thud jouer et ça va vous plaire on va
réviser toute l'actu grâce à la pizza
des la tue
[Musique]
mon père pensait ne plus lancer de
dingle puisque ce sont tous les mêmes
pas d'emmerdés non plus de manches et
alors c'est très simple aubin est-ce
qu'on a la vidéo
s'il vous plaît regardez la vidéo que
dix huit ce matin d'un couple voilà qui
s'amuse à regarder comme ils sont bons
on peut voir le début de la vidéo si
vous pouviez calais les vidéos
correctement merci regardez bah voilà
voilà ce à quoi m
c'est ça qu'on veut ok j'embrasse mes
parents les chéris c'est très simple
j'ai démarré par vous raymond ouais je
posais une question
allez-y si vous répondez bien raymond
c'est bon on nous répondait mal vous
désignerez quelqu'un qui mettra sa tête
dans la farine car une pizza ça débat
repart de l'attention
tout le monde a mis la farine sur son
coussin j'ai bossé l'actu aujourd'hui un
match de roland garros a été perturbé
pour quelle raison aurait mongole ou
alors c'est quand l'avion est passé et
qui a traversé le mur du son ça fait un
gros boum ça fait peur à tout le monde
et cet écrin brink a joué
c'est ce qu'a fait pas le plus selon lui
le hashtag ont été testés mur du son
baba au ces cette énorme bruit entendu
ce matin 11h50 donnant pratiquement
toute l'ile-de-france une détonation que
des millions de français ont entendu et
qui a inquiété beaucoup de monde
si beaucoup ont pensé une explosion
était très inquiète nos blondes on est
entre pleine réunion pour préparer
l'émission on est en train de boire un
coup le bruit en réalité était due à un
avion de chasse qui a franchi le mur du
son bar baba bye bye pour venir en aide
à un aéronef en perte de contact
alors évidemment tout le monde en a
parlé et ça fait la une de l'actu jour
d'hui regarde le rappel des principales
informations du jour avec cette nouvelle
si vous êtes à paris et en région
parisienne vous avez forcément entendu
cette détonation ce bruit importants
causés en fait par un avion de chasse
qui avait franchi le mur du son dans le
cadre d'une intervention d'urgence de
l'armée de l'air il s'agit en fait d'un
avion civil en braire qui faisait la
liaison brive saint brieuc et qui a
perdu momentanément le contact radio
avec la tour de contrôle avant de se
manifester à nouveau alors il le bruit a
donc résonné partout et même à la porte
d'auteuil à paris
roland garros et c'était mon ami mon
frérot mon joueur préféré stan wawrinka
bien sûr qui jouer sur le court suzanne
lenglen qui est en train de gagner bien
entendu il est justement bien entraîné
[Rires]
hélas beaucoup pensaient que c'était
benjamin castaldi cas des pays alors
vous savez à quoi ça ressemble un avion
qui franchit le mur du son oui moi je
pense est posée la question bien sûr à
ces visuels regarder au delà des images
vous allez voir si à regarder ça à 20h
nous sur ces vitrines
[Musique]
c'est impressionnant truc
oui je dise ah oui six pattes et il faut
ajouter quand même que c'est extrêmement
rare que c'est normalement c'est pas
légal les rafales qui passe comme ça ne
doivent pas traversé le mur du son
surtout sur paris c'est interdit c'était
la dirigeante d'urgente oui c'est un
métier là tout à l'heure merci pas sa
pensée la stan wawrinka qui m'appelle
mais alors il vaut mieux répond pas
je réponds attendait alors il est après
tout de suite stan wawrinka
quand joueur vainqueur de roland garros
vainqueur de l'open d'australie
vainqueur de l'us open et certainement
vainqueur de roland garros cette année
encore apparemment il ne peut plus me
parler très serré mon frère aussi à
l'antenne
[Rires]
ouais tu veux vraiment qu'on débranche
tout de suite oublier non non non ça va
te coucher où tu vas t'appeler après
l'émission pourquoi débris vraiment
parce que pour moi je vais te dire tout
est parfait et un mal bien sûr dos mais
je vais t'appeler après quand même parce
qu'il ya deux trois petites choses à
revoir
faucon moi c'est ta vie tu rencontres un
français ou que ce troisième tour mais
je sais non non je sais toi que tu
entraînes c'était un bon joueur et je
vais tenir moi je passe d'abord de façon
qu'ils pécuniaire la france est
important l'argent ainsi que je rappelle
que je fais ça bien sûr ils veulent voir
bénévolement un jeu de valve et voilà
les stades c'est une icône de mode et
une intelligence et d'une finesse c'est
soit ça avait aidé les rôles je t'aime
mon style je rappelle d'ailleurs mon
frérot et bravo encore time bomb
launcher
je t'embrasse l'eau et vous embrasse
tous ses skis et franchir un mur du son
est un
alors il est allé au delà ce match et
jamy mois qu'il y avait fait une vidéo à
l'époque dont jacques mercier qua non
c'est pas sorcier c'est 50 un avion vole
il fait pression sur l'herbe sous
l'effet de cette pression les molécules
qui constitue l'air vont et viennent et
se transmettent ce mouvement les unes
des autres à la vitesse de 340 mètres
seconde la vitesse du son maintenant
quand l'avion atteint 7 vitesses et bien
l'air qui va dans un sens n'a plus le
temps de revenir
il se forme alors un bourrelet d'air sur
le nez de l'avion etc ce bon les d'air
qui constitue le mur du son
vraiment eu des signaux qui pour mettre
la farine à ses partisans même en ville
bernard mais je vais prendre jean michel
parce que j'adore jean michel eeckhout
bah c'est pas beau cadeau que tu lui
fais jean michel c'est parti je rappelle
que le premier qui sera 3h de l'ovaire
du jeu de l'eau c'est parti la démo
johnny magnifique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi michel mr d'anecdotes sur le
mur du son sous le nom parce que j'ai
fait mon service militaire dans l'armée
de l'air et j'étais justement si jamais
cette tâche là j'étais à 30 mètres sous
terre à une prime sous béton et j'étais
chargé de regarder les lescop prada et
de déclencher la chasse quand un avion
est trop perdition ou qu'un avion ennemi
enfin est content with your enemy
franchissez les frontières françaises et
donc il y avait beaucoup d'avions de
l'urss en passe de réussir cet extrait
de passer les frontières françaises et
faisait souvent d'avoir d une perte de
le contact radio pour voir combien de
temps la chasse française mettait pour
les intercepter et tout ça a été étudié
pour essayer de déclencher le plus
rapidement possible la chasse française
et les pilotes français dorment dans
leur avion et sont toujours habillée
dans l'avion c'est l'autre déconner en
deux minutes à peu près donc à chaque
nuit à toute heure du moment de la nuit
du jour de la nuit à des pilotes qui
sont dollars abdou qui sont prêts à
décoller pour intercepter un avion en
détresse ou un avion
jean-michel l'air bien sûr info et
pizzas pour une bonne margherita photo
sauce tomate au japon la sauce tomate
maxime kenny question hier dans tpm pays
nathalie marquay a révélé avoir une
histoire d'amour avec une célébrité 2000
s'agissait-il la célébrité alors je les
ai vus oui je me souviens plus mais tu
sais d'une star alors assez mars est
mort c'était perco sous la boue
ah oui pire que seront la pierre collin
et canaux de la boum 2 ab oui fm est de
revenir alors là donc pas mal donc
maxime c'est donc farine plus chaudes
tomates maxime des bons retours un bon
retour il fallait regarder l'émission la
voix d'abord d'abord
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça va
denain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maxi maxi ce très bon mexique au coton
voir s'étaient jurés tirés nex connu ici
là ou un ex connu à part nathalie
marquée par le vent vous vous étiez qui
a non moi j'ai pas d'ex connu c'est vrai
mais on est et rhône
vous vous êtes kenza du loft
j'aime ça du loft ah ouais bah a craqué
pour lui c'est vrai que kenza du atelier
isabella kenzo encore à l'autre ouais
j'en ai encore un autre nom bah ouais
ouais je sais je vous dis casser la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'arrêter quoi patrick fiori avec
patrick bruel
oui patrick patrimoine ya longtemps
diarra sera à bbm n attendait que vous
êtes sortis et patrimoine oui mais genre
pendant combien de temps or à peine un
mois après je suis parti aux antilles
moi ouais et alors vous étiez amoureuse
non parce que je savais que de toute
façon ça ferait une histoire courte
armés c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
généreux extrêmement intelligent c'est
un amour ah oui quand vous voyez ça il
ya un petit et bien on s'est revu il ya
pas longtemps disons nettement pendant
les vacances et yann l'année dernière et
on était sur le même club et
jean-pierre il était au courant mais
cette fois-là petit jean pierre et puis
où elle s'est maintenant j'ai vu ses
enfants et ouais mais c'est quelqu'un de
super pas très franchement y en a un par
jour ça va on respecte at any 1
alors vous qui qui à l'heureuse paraît
que tu y as bernard way l'idée de nier
elle jouait dehors j'étais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle était l'héroïne d'une série est
reçu en france à l'aide américaine
française aller vite comme un domaine
les deux il est allé très vite après le
13e pas on a vécu ensemble
non on est resté bon ça va marcher sympa
les gens du palais reparti à los angeles
elle n'est pas des autographes tous les
journaux à l'époque la série passé beau
célébrités s'était et dans ce cas là
vous voulez sortir avec un héros de
série je vous auriez dû surtaxer bijoux
c'est vrai maxime est quoi coire est
sorti avec une tuque la sortie j'ai eu
un coup de coeur des débats mais j'ai
visé haut et j'ai eu un coup de coeur
pour l'animatrice ti gars qui présente
échappé alors ouais vous ai connu à
l'époque sur w9 on s'était vus dans une
soirée n'entraîne avec elle le principe
de pécho gyproc alors j'ai des invités à
une soirée au départ
ensuite je les ai invités au restaurant
je n'ai jamais revu la plaine morte à
new york faire une wii
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais entre temps ces revues mais on a
mis les mecs à sortent avec des
chroniqueurs à ce bar aux états unis
après veulent pouvoir me laver ses
services et à la batterie géant et
fatigue ou plutôt entre chez ce cas elle
vous met tout d'accord avec toi jordan
hassiba explique michael jordan mais non
on en avait déjà parlé mais oui ils ont
bien supporté que les censeurs c'est à
dire au maire pour une fois c'est qu'ils
ont mis la main au panier
[Rires]
non on le rappelle aucun accord peut
être sortis et que michael j'entends oui
mais c'était pas ça drôle
cela reste et tu la cua a jamais eu
d'aventuré 'qui ne valait plus que
maxime avec tag alors que c'est à dire
il ya de canaux des galoches vous allez
coucher
non mais ça va pas enfin depuis quand je
vais vous raconter si saisissant mais il
ya eu oui à la baleine soudera dit non
méritée non non vous inquiétez pas il
nous regarde pas mais c'est vraiment ma
carte mère ne regarde raconte l'amitié
des airs jordan une chose se lève à 56
oui ça va c'est vous dire le reste fait
une très mauvaise l'émission alors oui
oui oui en quoi
oui oui mais non non mais sinon bah oui
alors souris tu souris prescription
merci allez on aime avec isabelle on va
ajouter 1,9 sur votre farine au fait oui
il avait lui apprenant le match chelsea
tottenham alors ça c'est une vraie
saloperie un amateur
à matches de la première league est un
joueur qui a dû s'absenter pendant la
rencontre pour quelles raisons s'il
avait envie d'aller aux toilettes
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ces cantons monophonie
erreur de la banque en votre faveur
ouais exactement où l'oeil avant même si
vous êtes menteuse je vous aime bien
quand même
à moins d'un quart d'heure du match un
joueur qui a une envie soudaine d'aller
aux toilettes pour se soulager
sauf que ça n'a plus a pas plu du tout à
son entraîneur josé mourinho qui est
partie d'engueuler et le court c'est
dans les vestiaires regardez et il avait
vous désignerez quelqu'un dans un
instant qui finira presse que sa pizza
farine tomac et a9 bien entretenu
fromage et après on aura le clasico le
[Applaudissements]
josé mourinho est descendu dans le
tunnel parce qu'eric biais a foncé dans
les vestiaires pour utiliser les
toilettes
et revoilà héritiers il devait vraiment
avoir une envie pressante
[Applaudissements]
un joueur est parti aux toilettes
aucun alex émond mourinho n'avait pas y
est je pense quand même s'il vous plaît
[Rires]
j'ai une anecdote pour ça quand je joue
au foot c'est vrai reconnaît je crois
qu'il ya perdre
il ya patrick et une anecdote je vais
aux toilettes et ça dure plus longtemps
que prévu que sa défense a soit on croit
que c'est vite fait et ça et quand je me
lève pour repartir
olemps je me rende soit directe on est
obligé de demander le quart d'heure tu
as droit de demander un quart d'heure
pour décaler le match
du coup on a décalé maldague je sens que
ça va pas peur une anecdote de merde
isabelle mousset qui je peux pas dire
bernard parce qu'il va pas en parler
pendant dix ans mais quand tu nous as
fait chier vraiment je vais dire toi
[Applaudissements]
on peut toucher michael jordan est il
n'ya pas michael jordan ici c'est bon
merci je sens que ça va être très beau
sur vous attention la veille il avait
compris c'est ça bravo est maintenant un
petit peu trop mal si assez bord de même
débourser bien des pizzas c'était la
saison on va aller vite
question les cherry ne faut pas perdre
alors l'attention c'est la dernière
paire maintenant il prend tout où il
prend tout tout tout faux je vais je
vais choisir la tête en mai et après il
y aura la question bonus pour clément
guérin
ah oui s'il se plante tout le monde le
fera mais ceux qui l'ont déjà fait non
mais tout le frein à la tension j'ai
envie de passer dessus c'est pas vous
clément garde si vous répondez bien vous
serez tout le monde si vous répondez mal
tout le monde le fait au lof mois une
crise aux troubles si je pense se vouer
en fait vous allez avoir le poids de
l'équipe sur les épaules des d'arrivée
oui ah ouais on me pousse à 17h17 je
vous propose c'est qu'à 3 3 2 à pizza
merci à tous d'avoir avec nous
soirée
certes tous ses mandats
vainqueur
[Applaudissements]